right now corporate governance tims they
have a check box or almost compliance
approach what we have is a situation
where they'll be a blue-ribbon panel to
come out and say do you guys really need
to do something say everybody should
separate the CEO and chairman and things
like that we don't think that's very
useful in the governance arena because
the issues the topics the people vary
tremendously from company to company and
our perspective is let's really lay out
the essence of the problem bring in some
research insights and then and then give
the reader a setting to say here's
something had really happened what would
you actually do
where it gets really interesting boards
is something unexpected happens what
would you do if you know kind of one
example would be what would it what
would you do if the CEO unexpectedly
left you know do you really have a plan
in place have you really thought about
it sometimes you know because things are
going along fine you don't really think
carefully about what would happen if in
our book we pick up a variety of topics
that happen on a fairly regular basis
maybe haven't happened to you yet but I
probably likely going to happen what
happens if you have a big accounting
problem or is a big accounting
Restatement what if you get tremendous
push back from the outside about your
pay package you know those are things
that you want to think about ahead of
time as opposed to thinking about them
went when it actually happens one of the
most interesting chapters is on Royal
Dutch Shell that had an accounting
problem a few years ago where they
overstated the amount of oil that they
have in their proven reserves and they
did so by over twenty percent it was a
huge misstatement and the question was
why could something like this happen and
we have some very interesting
information in there where we look at
the structure of the organization
leadership changes cultural changes and
as well as some actual dialogue and and
emails and conversation that took place
among executives and you can see how a
company can potentially have breakdowns
and its internal controls that can lead
to a problem
one of the things we pride ourself on
here at Stanford is we want to base our
recommendations or base our thinking on
real research we tend to take into
account you know what experts in the
field say or what blue ribbon panel say
but all we want to ask the question does
that work or doesn't it so we've tried
to embed that in the book but in a very
specific setting where what would you do
if you were you were confronted with
this kind of request for compensation or
what would you do if you had this kind
of board structure and I think it
provides a really interesting learning
experience in a fairly tight manner but
where it really gets into the essence of
the problem and I think that's what
corporate governance needs to do be
based on research be based on fact and
then also be based on careful thinking